the representation of women on company
boards is on the agenda as EU ministers
responsible for employment Social Policy
health and consumer affairs meet in
Luxembourg discussion will be based on a
progress report on possible measures to
improve gender balance at the top of
Europe's companies the European
Commission wants to increase the number
of women on non executive boards to
forty percent by 2020 EU nations support
the principle of improving the gender
balance although some countries believe
this should be done at the national
level while others prefer eu-wide
legislation health ministers will be
updated on draft rules for medical
devices like corrective glasses dental
filling material x-ray machines heart
valves or breast implants and on in
vitro diagnostic devices like blood
tests the revision of EU laws on medical
devices is aimed at providing high
protection for European patients
consumers and healthcare professionals
and to ensure that safe and effective
equipment is readily available ministers
will also look at what impact the
economic crisis had on health care
systems and suggest ways to make the
sector more resilient to future shocks
the council will also look at nutrition
and physical activity given that up to
seven percent of EU health budgets are
directly spent each year on disease
linked to obesity the minister's aim to
propose measures to encourage the
promotion of physical activity and a
healthy diet